THREE MINUTES NOW, AND YOU HAVE
TO BE SMART, AND USE SOME TIME,
AND SET UP THE RIGHT PEOPLE.
>> Ryan: HARDEN ON THE ATTACK,
AND TURNS IT OVER.
IT IS TWO-ON-ONE, AND YOUNG IS
REJECTED BY DURANT WHO LUWAWU
CABARROT CAN'T FINISH.
HERE COMES DURANT WITH THE
PULL-UP JUMPER, AND YOU BET!
WHAT A SEQUENCE FROM KEVIN
DURANT.
>> Hubie: THAT IS MONEY AT ONE
END, AND MORE MONEY AT THE
OTHER.
IT IS BEAUTIFUL DEFENSE.
GREAT PLAY, AND NATURALLY, WHEN
YOU GOT HARDEN AND TWO GUYS THAT
WANT TO FINISH --
>> Hubie: OH, NO, COME ON.
>> Ryan: TRAE YOUNG AND KEVIN
DURANT ARE GETTING INTO IT HERE,
AND A COUPLE OF COMPETITORS.
>> Hubie: NOW, LOOK, AS SOON AS
THEY CAME OVER THE HALF-COURT,
KEVIN PICKED HIM UP.
HE WAS GOING TO PLAY HIM
MAN-TO-MAN, OKAY.
THAT IS THE FIRST TIME IN THIS
GAME THAT KEVIN SWI